Transcription: Mandy Vincent
Relecteur: eric vautier
Il y a une question
que vous devez vous poser.
Pourquoi je suis ici
devant vous aujourd’hui ?
Qui suis-je ?
Et qu’est-ce que j’ai de bien
assez important à vous dire
pour qu’on me laisse
l’opportunité de vous le dire ?
Alors, je vais vous raconter une histoire,
mon histoire,
et comment, mardi 25 mai 2021,
je me retrouve sur la scène TEDx.
Le 15 mai 1997, Béatrice et François Maron
ont donné naissance à un bébé
à 18h35, prénommé Léa.
J’ai atterri en France, dans le Jura
et plus précisément dans la petite ville
de Lons-le-Saunier.
J'ai eu une enfance tout à fait classique.
Je suis allée sur les bancs
de l’école française.
J'ai eu mon bac.
Puis s’en est suivie la question du :
« Qu’est-ce que je veux faire
de ma vie ? »
Vous savez, cette fameuse question,
un peu angoissante,
qu’on nous demande de nous poser
à environ 17-18 ans.
Et en sachant que nous allons passer
les deux tiers de notre vie à travailler,
bien souvent pour une entreprise,
on se dit qu’il ne faut pas trop se louper
quant à la réponse à cette question.
Et il est vrai que je me demandais
pourquoi cette question du :
« Qu’est-ce que je veux faire
de ma vie ? »,
nous la rapportons systématiquement
à notre vie professionnelle.
Pourquoi ?
La bonne réponse ne pourrait-elle pas
être : « Ce que je veux faire,
c’est être bien dans ma vie
et être heureuse »
Et ce qui va dépendre de mon bonheur
va évoluer au gré de mes expériences,
mes rencontres, mes envies et aspirations.
Car ma vie n’est pas figée et tout cela
va dépendre de mon évolution.
Réponse utopiste, vous allez
me dire, et non recevable.
Et si je vous disais pourtant
que c’est la réponse que j’ai eue
et que j’applique chaque jour de ma vie ?
Et en répondant de cette façon
à cette question,
je suis devenue actrice de ma vie.
Nous jouons tous
les scénarios de notre vie
et notre existence se déroule
telle une pièce de théâtre.
Nous sommes comme des comédiens
à façonner notre vie,
à jouer chaque scénario de celle-ci.
Nous pouvons tous nous féliciter,
car nous avons déjà tous été le héros,
le protagoniste d’une histoire,
de notre propre histoire.
Nous jouons en simultané nos scénarios,
sur une scène commune,
avec un décor commun,
notre chère planète Terre.
Nous connaissons tous
le scénario classique :
il faut réussir ses études,
partir à la quête d’un premier emploi,
trouver sa moitié et devenir propriétaire.
Et je vous épargne la suite.
Mais est-ce que cette projection est
une projection commune,
que tout le monde doit vivre ?
Parce que, si c’est le cas, ce serait
quand même une bien triste réalité.
Je pense plutôt que nous avons tous
notre propre chemin à vivre,
mais faut-il encore trouver lequel.
Pour ça, tel un voyage intérieur,
nous devons partir à la réelle découverte
de nous-même, de qui nous sommes,
de notre singularité,
s’intérioriser, se poser des questions,
à savoir quelle histoire,
quelle vie nous voulons vivre,
et une fois que nous avons trouvé,
mobiliser toute notre énergie
dans cette direction.
Alors, je me suis posé des questions,
à savoir quelle vie je veux expérimenter ?
Première réponse :
une vie pleine de surprises
qui laisse place aux rebondissements.
Parce que tout n’est
qu’impermanence dans la vie.
Rien ne dure,
pas même notre propre existence.
J’ai tâtonné et je suis partie à Dijon
faire des études de communication
mais il me manquait de l’aventure.
Alors, après avoir obtenu mon BTS,
à 20 ans, je suis partie bagage en main,
ne parlant pas un mot d’anglais,
direction les États-Unis.
Je peux vous assurer qu’une fois
arrivée là-bas, je me suis dit :
« Mais pourquoi tu as fait ça ? »
On me parlait, je ne comprenais rien,
je répondais des « yes »,
mais à force d’efforts, j’ai commencé
à comprendre un peu, à parler
et ce fut une expérience de dingue.
Ensuite, je suis revenue en France et j’ai
repris mes études en communication.
Et au bout d’un an, avec toujours
cette soif d’aventures au ventre,
je suis repartie,
cette fois-ci,
explorer la Nouvelle-Zélande et l’Asie.
J’avais un peu plus l’anglais
que la première fois aux États-Unis
et ça, c’était cool.
Mais la nouveauté résidait
dans le type d’habitation.
Je suis partie vivre en van.
Je ne sais pas
si vous avez déjà vécu en van
mais c’est toute une expérience.
C’est-à-dire qu’on vit
dans à peu près cinq mètres carrés.
Se faire à manger et prendre une douche,
c’est toute une aventure.
Mais revenir à l'essentiel, c'est cool
et ça m'a fait le plus grand bien.
Et en voyant mes différents voyages,
il est vrai qu’on me disait souvent :
« Mais tu vas finir tes études quand ?
Vas-tu vraiment les finir un jour ? »
« Et attention ! Tu vas avoir des trous
dans ton CV »
« A quel âge vas-tu trouver
ton premier emploi ? »
Et tout ça, en fait, je m’en fichais.
Je m’en fichais parce que je vivais
ce que j’avais envie de vivre
au moment où j’avais envie de le vivre.
Mais attention,
pas de manière stupide ou inconsciente,
avec un cap,
en sachant très bien où j’allais
et en écrivant l’histoire
que j’ai envie de raconter
et que je vous raconte aujourd’hui.
Du coup, j’ai une question pour vous :
savez-vous ce qui vous fait vibrer ?
Quels sont vos rêves ?
Et, si vous le savez,
qu’est-ce qui vous empêche
de les réaliser ?
Je me suis aperçue
que nous avons une dissonance
entre ce que nous aimerions faire et vivre
et ce que nous faisons réellement.
Ça, parce que nous pouvons lister
un nombre incalculable de contraintes
que nous pensons avoir,
empêchant la réalisation
de nos envies profondes.
Des contraintes liées à
notre situation financière,
notre environnement, notre âge, etc.
Mais est-ce que ces contraintes sont
vraiment des contraintes valables ?
Où ce ne serait pas ce qu’on appelle
plus communément des excuses ?
Car oui, nous pouvons avoir
des millions d’excuses
et il est bien plus simple de se trouver
des excuses que d’essayer,
sûrement par peur de se tromper,
devoir recommencer, réessayer.
Et nous avons aussi tous des tas de peurs,
peur de l’insécurité, du manque,
du changement,
de sortir de notre zone de confort.
Alors oui, l'inconnu fait peur.
Mais il s’agit d’oser, oser être soi-même
et s’affranchir du regard des autres,
du poids familial, de la société.
Et au final, ne pas se restreindre
par les barrières que nous nous mettons
nous-mêmes.
J’ai également remarqué qu’en France,
nous ne sommes pas éduqués à l’échec.
Ce mot « échec »
à connotation si négative.
L'échec fait peur.
Et nous devons réussir du premier coup,
ne pas changer de voie ou de direction.
Mais ce raisonnement
nous limite tellement,
car du coup, nous n’essayons pas,
par peur de nous tromper.
Mais au final, nous allons
toujours tirer du profit
dans chaque expérience de notre vie.
Et il y a toujours quelque chose
à apprendre, à comprendre.
Et ça,
c’est déjà une forme de réussite.
Depuis mon retour de Nouvelle-Zélande,
je suis en création d’entreprise,
alors que je n’ai aucune compétence
dans l’entrepreneuriat
et je souhaite créer une entreprise
dans un domaine, où de base,
je ne connais absolument rien.
Et tout ça, c’est OK.
Peut-être que mon projet
ne verra jamais le jour
mais tout ce que j’aurai appris, compris,
toutes les interactions que j’aurai eues
avec des personnes incroyables
grâce à ce projet,
ça, c’est ce qui importe le plus.
Vivre par l'action.
Avec de la volonté,
on peut arriver à presque tout.
Il ne faut pas sous-estimer
notre capacité à apprendre et à créer.
Car nous sommes créateurs et nous sommes
créateurs des scènes que nous jouons,
nous les créons de par nos choix,
car notre vie consiste
en une série de multitudes de choix.
Car nous avons toujours le choix.
Le choix de faire ou de ne pas faire.
Comme là, vous avez le choix de m’écouter
ou de ne pas le faire.
Demain, vous aurez le choix
de vous lever pour aller au travail
ou de rester chez vous.
Alors, si vous restez chez vous,
cela aura sûrement une conséquence,
mais vous avez le choix.
Le tout est de savoir si vous êtes
OK ou non avec cette conséquence.
Nous utilisons notre libre arbitre
à chaque instant de notre vie.
De ce fait, nous sommes complètement
responsables de notre existence
et de nos décisions.
Nous ne pouvons plus nous défiler
et remettre la faute sur quelque chose
ou quelqu’un d’autre, mais seulement
endosser notre propre responsabilité.
Il y a environ trois semaines,
j’ai vécu un grave accident de voiture.
Ceci explique cela.
J’ai fait un saut de six mètres.
Je peux affirmer déjà
que j’ai volé en voiture.
Et je me suis réveillée
dans cette voiture broyée
et une force de vivre a pris le dessus.
Je me suis relevée et j’ai marché,
monté une butte,
croisé le chemin de quelqu’un
qui m’a conduite aux urgences.
On m’appelle aujourd’hui la miraculée,
je m’en tire avec un bras fracturé
et une paralysie de mon nerf radial
qui empêche en très grande partie
la mobilité de ma main gauche.
Cette situation,
je ne peux pas la changer.
Mais je peux choisir comment
réagir face à ces circonstances.
J’ai le choix entre me morfondre
et pleurnicher sur mon sort
ou j’ai le choix de me battre
pour récupérer la fonction
de ma main gauche
et le plus rapidement possible.
J’ai le choix de prendre le positif
et plutôt que de voir ce que j’ai perdu,
voir ce que j’ai gardé
car ça aurait pu être bien pire.
J’aurais pu aussi annuler
cette présentation TEDx et ne pas venir
mais les enseignements
que j’ai tirés de cette situation
ne font qu’une fois de plus,
appuyer mon discours.
Tout change, tout le temps.
Nous pensons avoir le temps
mais c’est un leurre.
La vie file et elle n’attend personne.
Alors, qu’est-ce qu’il y a
de plus important
que de vivre ce que nous voulons,
intrinsèquement, le plus vivre.
Avec cette histoire,
je veux vous partager
une leçon d’humilité, de courage
et d’espoir.
Il faut se battre pour
ce qu’on désire le plus.
Laissons tomber les masques
et incarnons ce que nous voulons être.
Il y a quand même une petite nuance
à apporter à ce discours,
car tout à l’heure, je vous disais que
nous partageons une scène commune,
et effectivement, nous la partageons avec
plus de 7,6 autres milliards d’individus,
vivants sur la même surface terrestre
que nous.
Nous sommes donc les acteurs
d’une scène beaucoup plus vaste
et beaucoup plus grande,
celle de l’humanité tout entière.
Nous sommes tous connectés
et interdépendants.
Déjà, d’une part,
par l’habitat commun que nous partageons.
Alors oui, nous pouvons décider
de la vie que nous voulons vivre
mais nous avons quand même
une part de responsabilité
face à ces autres personnes
car tout à l’heure,
nous avons vu que les actions
que nous faisons ont des conséquences
et elles ont des conséquences
sur notre vie
mais elles ont également
des conséquences sur l’ensemble,
qu’elles soient positives ou négatives.
Et il est vrai que plus
une conséquence est lointaine,
moins nous en prenons conscience.
Pour autant, ce n’est pas parce
qu’une conséquence est lointaine
qu’elle n’existe pas.
Alors, quand nous faisons une action
qui altère cet habitat commun,
nous empiétons sur la vie
que peuvent avoir d’autres personnes.
Et cet habitat commun, il nous fournit
l’eau, l’air, la nourriture
dont nous avons besoin pour vivre.
C’est notre essence vitale.
D'où la nécessité de le préserver.
Nos actions d’aujourd’hui vont orienter
les scènes que va jouer l’humanité
dans les mois et les années à venir.
Alors, sur cette scène globale,
quel rôle voulez-vous jouer ?
Gardons-le à l’esprit
et posons-nous la question :
quel impact je veux pour ma vie,
la vie des autres, des générations futures
et de toutes les personnes qui rentrent
en interaction avec moi-même
car nous sommes tous responsables.
J’ai pris réellement conscience
et j’ai mis en œuvre ce rôle d’acteur
que nous avons.
Et à tout juste 24 ans,
j’ai vécu dans trois pays différents,
passant un bac +3 en France,
des certifications aux États-Unis,
effectué plus de vingt jobs différents.
J’ai discuté, échangé,
appris avec des centaines
et des centaines de personnes,
commencé une aventure entrepreneuriale
et fait un TEDx.
Pourtant, je ne suis pas quelqu’un
avec des compétences incroyables,
des capacités innées
ou un portefeuille ultra bien rempli.
Je n’ai jamais gagné plus que le SMIC
et pourtant, je ne me suis jamais privée.
Ce qui m’a portée ?
Une confiance accrue dans la vie.
Une volonté de fer
et une détermination sans faille.
Je suis actrice de ma vie
et j’écris chaque scénario.
Tout le monde peut vivre
ce qu’il désire le plus.
La différence réside dans le fait
de s’en donner les moyens ou non
et dans un respect des autres acteurs
qui partagent la même scène que nous.
Alors oui, changer nos scénarios
peut changer notre vie
et la vie qu’auront
les générations futures.
Tout est possible.
Donnons-nous les moyens
de réaliser nos rêves.
La vie est trop courte
pour la regarder défiler.
Montons dans le wagon, prenons les rênes
et devenons ce que nous voulons être.
Alors maintenant,
à vous d’écrire votre histoire.
Rêvez,
osez,
créez.
Merci.